hey Troy and Gabriella we can't believe
it's been nearly 14 years since high
school musical premiered well with the
wasting tonight that's pretty hard to
believe we wondered what the two of you
are up to these days
hopefully you're still together it must
be pretty cool to know that people are
still totally obsessed with you
so much so that there's a whole new high
school musical series
[Music]
we wonder what you and all your friends
think about it the new high school
musical series on Disney Plus is getting
a lot of love from fans and critics what
does the new version have in common with
the original movies
what's different keep watching for an
in-depth comparison of the two high
school musicals the style the style of
the new High School Musical is the
biggest difference between the two the
original film was a classic teen movie
it's the style that were used to seeing
on Disney Channel the original book took
place at a regular high school there
were the theater kids the smart kids and
the jocks Troy was a jock who wanted to
impress one of the smart girls he met
over the holidays by trying out for the
high school musical the movie was all
about the teens and how they reacted to
blending their social groups and it was
Troy and Gabriella slavs story it really
wasn't even about the musical the new
high school musical is a mockumentary
it's about the school where the original
was filmed they put on a production of
high school musical so the original was
a musical about a musical whereas the
new one is a musical about a musical
about a musical it's musical inception I
don't hate musicals I just think it's
weird when people like burst into song
in the middle of the streets we love the
mockumentary style of the new show the
way the actors break the fourth wall and
talked to the camera is so cool the
important thing is to have patience and
trust that a breakthrough will happen
the premise even though the style of the
show is different the storyline has some
similarities in the original movie Troy
realizes he likes singing when he meets
Gabriella they sing a cute love song
together he decides to try out for the
musical to get to know her better he
wasn't really into musical theater at
all the guy who gets cast as Troy and
the new version also isn't a huge
theater geek like the others Riki is
doing it to impress Nini who is cast as
Gabriella hey I take this series that
sounds really familiar there are some
major differences though there's not a
huge divide between the docks and the
theatre kids and
other than Troy all the kids in the
musical really want to be there there's
not a lot of shaking up the status quo
between the cliches it's more focused on
the interpersonal relationships of the
characters the Troy's the og Troy was
played by Zac Efron way back in 2006
it's hard to believe that Zac was ever
that young and the original high school
musical Troy Bolton was a basketball
jock the school had a great basketball
team and Troy was the star player but
you're not just a guy Troy the team
leader he was expected to get a
basketball scholarship and everything
that whole storyline was the premise of
High School Musical 2 Zac Efron has a
great voice lots of love because they
get it but in the first movie some of
his singing parts were dubbed by another
actor since Zac was busy filming
hairspray for a lot of it the new Troy
is played by Joshua Bessette he
definitely doesn't look like Zach joshua
plays a ricky bowen he's not a jock at
all instead he's a guitar player so we
know he loves music already he's a
junior in high school he previously
dated Nene and is trying to win her back
the Gabriella's in the first movie
Gabriela is a new student at East High
School her family had just moved to the
area the original Gabriela was played by
none other than Vanessa Hudgens this
movie is what really made her famous in
the original Gabriella is made out to be
a total geek she's super smart
especially in science
she is also a member of the Scholastic
Decathlon team she's really shy and
struggles with her audition for the
school musical the new Gabriella has a
lot of differences Olivia Rodrigo plays
Mimi Salazar Roberts she is totally
annoyed by Ricky's attempts to win her
back she is a huge fan of musical
theater and is really excited about the
musical one really cool thing about the
new Gabriella is that she's more than
just an actress Olivia Rodrigo wrote
some of the music for the new show she
wrote the song all I want for the
November 29th episode the teacher do you
remember the theater teacher from the
original high school musical don't feel
bad if you don't the teacher was meant
to be a very small background role the
focus of the franchise was on teenagers
and honestly that's pretty typical of
Disney Channel but here's a refresher if
you don't remember her the original
drama teacher was mrs. darvis she was
played by Alison Reed and she was in the
first and the last movies in the new
high school musical the teacher is a
major character her name is Miss Jen and
she is a young new teacher at East High
she is definitely reliving her glory
days her character was a backup dancer
in the original movies she's so excited
to be at East High and is obsessed that
the school has never done a production
of High School Musical she's hilarious
and over the top I added the kiss
because miss Jin is played by Kate
Reynders who is not in the original
movies like her character the settings
you might think that the settings of the
to high school musicals are the same
after all they are both set at East High
School right well it's actually a lot
more complicated than that
we know that movies are often shot at
different locations than they take place
and that's what it's happening with the
new High School Musical the original
movie took place in Albuquerque New
Mexico the new TV series also takes
place at East High School but this
version of East High School is set in
Salt Lake City Utah that's a lot farther
north in Albuquerque the actual schools
do look very similar but it has been a
long time since the original movies the
original movies were shot in Salt Lake
City parts were filmed at the
real East High School and others were
filmed at Murray high school this could
be the start of something new if you
subscribe to the things for more awesome
videos about all things Disney Plus
click that big red subscribe button if
you're watching on your mobile put the
Settings icon
to make sure your notifications are
turned on stay tuned to find out all
about the music in the new High School
Musical series the tone one of the
biggest differences between the new and
old high school musicals is the overall
tone the original version was pretty
standard for Disney Channel it's super
wholesome it's completely
family-friendly any kid of any age could
watch the original and not see anything
they didn't get it dealt with real teen
issues but they weren't too deep things
like blending cliques are something that
anyone can understand the humor was
definitely targeting the younger
audience the new high school musical is
a complete 180 it's fresh and edgy
there's a level of sarcasm that just
isn't in anything we've ever seen from
Disney Channel it bleeps out bad words
while the original didn't put any swear
words in the script it has a more
grown-up feeling and is trying to reach
older teenagers shar-pei isn't played by
a girl Mimi's best friend calls herself
a feminist well we can scratch out
number 6 because that's an act of war
Disney Plus is really setting itself
apart from Disney Channel the other
characters a new version of a movie
comes with a whole new cast of
characters the biggest difference is
Sharpay ashley tisdale was the spoiled
dramatic diva from the original movies
Sharpay is played by a boy named Seb in
the new version sab is a theatre fanatic
played by Joe Serafini
Troy's best friend and High School
Musical is Chad Danforth Corbin Bleu was
the original Chad in the new show cha
display by Ricky's rival EJ EJ is a jock
and musical theater nerd who met Nene at
theater camp there's nothing for you to
be nervous about you went on this summer
for the lead role with 20 minutes notice
you didn't miss a beat he's played by
Matt Cornett
Sophia Wiley plays the competitive Geena
Porter she is cast as Taylor Gabriella's
best friend but she
really wants the role of Gabriella the
original tailor was played by Monique
Coleman there are some totally new
characters to Ricky's best friend is a
guy named big red do you even know the
plot of High School Musical who is
played by Larry Saperstein Nene's best
friend is Kourtney the actress who plays
her is Darin a and we can't forget about
Carlos he's a Broadway obsessed
melodramatic teen who is choreographing
the production of High School Musical at
East High carlos is played by Frankie
Rodriguez this structure obviously there
is a huge difference between the
structures of the to high school
musicals the original version was a
movie it's one of the most successful
Disney Channel movies ever made it was
so popular that it got two sequels the
new version is a TV show with ten
episodes in the first season and it's
already been renewed for a second season
because of the series we get a lot more
time to get to know the characters we
can really dive into their storylines
and character development
honestly we often wish that the original
movies were longer we can't wait to find
out what the second season will be about
will the students at East High try to
put on a production of High School
Musical 2 it's also filmed in a
different style mockumentaries or fake
documentaries are totally a fun
structure for a TV show and it is still
a musical to the music let's be honest
one of the best parts of the original
movies is the music there are so many
great songs like start of something new
and get your head in the game we learned
how to stick to the status quo and bop
to the top the love songs were amazing
and who can forget that the students
learned that we're all in this together
we have already heard some of these
songs in the new series and we'll hear
their best throughout the season it's
always a little scary to find out if new
versions of the songs are going to be as
good as the original but we love the new
versions too there's also a lot of new
music Nene and Ricky are amazing singers
we love the song I think I kinda you
know there's wondering and a billion
sorry's plus olivia Rodrigo made her
songwriting debut with all I want it's
so beautiful we can't wait for even more
new songs but we still love all the
original music - and that's a wrap
are you watching the new high
School Musical series who's your
favorite new character let us know in
the comments thanks for watching show
Troy and Gabriella some love by clicking
that big thumbs up button see you next
time
[Music]